Narrator:
This is the shark tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of getting
an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We did $3.7 million
in sales last year.
Wow.
Whoa.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
When you walk
into the shark tank,
you look for the sucker,
and if you don't see one,
it's you.
If the sharks
hear a great idea...
Oh!
Wow.
...they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I'm gonna spice it up here
in the shark tank a little bit.
Narrator: And they're
willing to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
So, you're one
handshake away.
So, let me stop you and make you
think about something.
What Lori does well
is she sells product.
What I do well
is I build power brands.
Ooh. It's like a gunfight
at the O.K. Corral.
Narrator:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first Internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Grenier, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
is a couple from North Carolina
with a company for fashionable
children everywhere.
Aww.
Ohh.
Corcoran:
Oh, look at them.
Oh, he's got
a little pocket thing, too.
Love the outfit.
Hi, sharks.
We are the Schaub family.
I'm Amber.
I'm Mark.
And this is
Aubrey and Jonas.
And our company
is Rufflebutts,
and we're offering
a 7% equity stake
in exchange
for $600,000.
[ Chuckles ]
Yes, Rufflebutts.
We put adorable ruffles
on cute, little tushies
all over the world.
[ Laughs ]
It was six years ago
that I went out in search
for a baby gift.
I was looking for those
little ruffled bloomers
my mom always called
"Rufflebutts."
It's when I realized they
were nowhere to be found
that our company
was born.
Our company started around
a simple baby bloomer,
but we now design
and manufacture
an entire clothing line
for girls up to age 6.
And after too many
customer requests to ignore,
we added a boy's line
named Ruggedbutts.
Being super-cute
is top priority.
Equally as important
is quality.
Thank you.
And lastly,
thank you.
Learning from
my frugal mom,
affordable
to the masses.
Thank you so much.
Amber: And, mark,
this one is for Alyssa.
Thanks, Amber.
Cute.
Is that cute?
Mark:
We are so proud
of what Amber's little idea
has become.
So, sharks, what do
you need to know
to come join this ruffled
revolution with us?
Okay, Jonas,
go with sissy.
No!
There's skittles
down there.
[ Laughs ]
You want to go home
with sissy?
Aww.
See, he didn't agree
with the valuation
before it came out.
[ Laughs ]
Amber, you have a big number
on this business.
Tell us about your sales.
Absolutely.
We did $3.7 million
in sales last year.
Awesome.
And we are on track to
do between $4.5 and
$5 million this year.
Wow.
We started, we were
profitable in year one,
and we have grown
every year since.
We actually landed
on the inc. 500 list
at number eight
in all of retail.
This adorable little red outfit
with the ruffle bottom,
what do you sell it for?
They're right around
$25 apiece.
Great value.
Cuban: So, you probably have
debt right now.
You probably have --
no debt?
Wow.
Who owns the company?
I own 51%
and Mark's at 49%.
Oh, now we know who --
smart lady! Yeah!
Now we know
who wears the ruffles.
Herjavec: Wow, Mark,
I feel so bad for you.
He -- [ Laughs ]
So, how many skus
do you have?
So, I believe
it's about 700 skus...
Whoa.
Wow.
Whoa!
...in the ruffled bloomers.
Between colors
and styles and sizes.
You know where
I'm going with this.
You don't need 700 skus.
Just -- just to qualify,
we actually have around
700 skus of bloomers.
We've got
around 2,000 skus.
Wow.
That's even more insane.
Well, here's the thing,
I mean, as you guys know,
with a fashion line, we have to
keep it fresh and hip.
The amount of money
that you're asking for today
is less than
you're gonna generate
in terms of cash this year.
Why do you need the money,
and why the specific amount
of $600,000?
Production, obviously
ramping up to build inventory.
We absolutely, again, value
every one of the five of you
as amazing strategic
partners.
We want your expertise.
We want your advice.
What you're saying is,
as you're growing
and continuing to expand,
it's just nice
to have someone
to bounce ideas off of.
You're exactly right.
Amber, tell us a little bit more
about yourself.
I was in real estate,
and I found a lot of success,
but there was
something missing.
And I was really lacking
the fulfillment
that I needed from my career,
and there was this --
creating a product,
is that what was lacking there?
It was really this...
Entrepreneurial bug,
I guess I could say.
Do you have competitors
out there
that are making styles
like yours?
Currently, we don't have
any one specific competitor
that we would say,
"they do exactly what we do."
2,700 skus
in a $5-million business --
that is a massive
red flag to me.
I-I experienced this
myself.
My family started a business
called "Kiddies Togs,"
winter clothing
for children.
Exact same trajectory.
What nearly killed us
is when we went past 200 skus.
Let me tell you
a little story
that comes from Greek mythology
I think you're gonna enjoy,
'cause I'm seeing it
right in front of me.
Zeus married a woman
named Demeter.
They had a daughter
named Persephone.
Everybody wanted to marry her,
including Hades.
[ Chuckles ]
One day she was
picking flowers
'cause she was always tempted
to go for more colors.
The earth opened, she fell
into the bowels of hell.
Oh, no!
Is there a point?
Yeah, you're gonna
get to it in a second.
You're gonna learn something,
too. Here we are in hell.
Yes, we are in hell.
Persephone,
the most beautiful woman.
Okay!
His home.
And Hades knows that she's
constantly tempted for more.
Even when she's blessed
with beauty, she wants more.
I think what's happening here is
you're being tempted
every day to expand more
and more and more.
To me,
you are persephone.
You have been tempted
by the devil of inventory,
and having learned from Zeus,
I'm out.
Cuban:
Guys, here's what I see.
You're creating
this whole portfolio
of products all the time.
You have an idea, you see
a trend, you want to fill it.
As you design new things,
you have to see what sticks.
You have to see what works.
Right.
Which gets to where
you have all those skus, right?
But that takes
a lot of cash, right?
'Cause you don't know
what your home runs are
until you try them.
That's great for you.
Bad for me because
the best bloomer in the world,
I got no clue.
And for that reason,
I have to say I'm out.
Thank you.
I think it is remarkable
you've gotten to this point
without any debt.
I couldn't have done that.
I-I can't help you
on a daily basis.
I wish I could.
I know how
to grow businesses,
but I don't understand
the fashion part,
as Mark said,
or the other stuff.
I'm out.
Okay, we have
two sharkettes left.
Why don't you start,
Barbara?
No, because she's gonna
come in under me and outdo me.
No way.
Well, then why don't you two
sharks get together?
If you think
you're the better partner,
what difference
would it make?
Because it's always better
to go less, and you know it.
Speak up, my friend.
Ooh. It's like a gunfight
at the O.K. Corral.
Narrator:
Three sharks are out.
Barbara and Lori
are Mark and Amber's last chance
to make a deal.
Lori, what do you have
in your head?
Greiner: You know, I really --
I seriously,
I was thinking, Barb.
I, uh, I wasn't trying to go
first or last against you.
Well, I was definitely
trying to go last.
I really have been
thinking about this
because they are asking
for $600,000 for 7%, so...
You find that
a little light, perhaps?
I find it
a little light.
I'll put an offer
on the table.
You rarely in business
get a super-creative
who's really good
at business judgment.
It rarely comes together,
and you happen to have
both pieces of that.
I'm gonna give you an offer
for $600,000 --
$300,000 in cash,
$300,000 in a
as-you-need-it-basis credit line
for 12% of your business.
First, let me tell you
that we sincerely appreciate
your offer.
We're so grateful
to be here,
and we just are thrilled
that you would want to
be a part in this with us.
And you are one good
schmoozer, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Wow.
So, with that,
that valuation
puts our company
close to what we're going to do
in revenue this year.
I assume that is
a very sweet note.
Well, listen.
[ Laughs ]
There's no assumption.
The biggest challenge
is the equity and valuation.
Those two kids that you saw
walk out of this room,
all of this is for them,
so every -- every ounce
of equity that we give up,
that's theirs,
but we also understand
the value that you bring
to this
and what you can create for
them, which is why we're here.
You two are very much
like my husband and myself.
And I completely understand
both of you.
I get you.
I have lived it for 17 years.
So, here's my offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $600,000 for 10%,
but I'd like to get back
the first $300,000
within the first year
and the next in the second year.
I want to clarify one thing.
What Lori does well
is she sells product.
What I do well
is I build power brands.
And I've done it
with every business
I've invested in
on "shark tank."
And by the way, as a --
well, I've built
a $500-million power brand.
Yes, of course.
So, I don't think...
Lori, may I finish, please?
...that what she's saying
is really necessary.
No, no. I'm not --
I'm not knocking it.
Are you staying at your offer,
or are you changing it?
No, no. They can respond
to the offer,
all right?
Okay.
The offers are very close
to each other.
Who do you want to
work with?
Lori's is just a loan.
May I mention to you
the $300,000
is a one-year loan
for equity.
It's more than a loan.
It's a lifetime
of experience.
But do you understand
the offers?
And I'll just say that
my experience is in retail.
Barbara's is in real estate
with some "shark tank" deals.
Some "shark --"
okay, stop.
Both of you, stop.
17 years
of experience.
Do you ha--
do you need
any more information?
We honestly would be
beyond honored
to work with
either one of you.
I mean, obviously to me, you are
both inspirational women,
so it is definitely
something
we need to talk about
and process.
I appreciate it.
Amber, this is business.
Go make a decision.
Got it.
Okay.
Wow.
That's interesting.
Does that affect the long-term
value of our company?
Yeah. I mean, it's --
the main reason here
is the strategic partnership
with either one of them.
Possibly.
Lori, that's the worst deal
you've ever offered to somebody.
Mark!
In fact --
I'm just telling you.
I'm just telling you the facts.
That's a Kevin deal.
O'Leary: No, it isn't!
It's a very smart,
financially astute deal.
For her,
not for them.
Oh, that --
that's right.
That is a Kevin deal.
It is a Kevin deal.
Let's summarize
what we've got here.
So, Barbara's offer
was the $600,000 for 12%.
However, $300,000 of that
is actually a loan
you have to pay back.
Lori's offer --
10% equity for the $600,000,
but she wants her money back
in 24 months.
What are you going to do?
We absolutely see the value
in strategic partnership
with working
with either one of you.
What our counter
would be --
the same $600,000
in exchange for 8% equity.
Would you compromise
at 10%?
If I met you halfway,
would you go the other half?
Barbara, I-I want to with
everything I have standing here,
but I-I-I just can't.
For me,
I feel 10% is right.
Lori, can I ask you,
is that the highest valuation
that you're willing
to put on the company?
I'll go 9%, that's it.
So, I think
at this point,
you really have to decide, what
do you feel is right for you?
What do you feel in your gut
is best?
All right, Lori.
You have a deal.
Yay!
Wow. Whoo.
Thank you!
I'm very excited.
Herjavec: Nice job, mark.
You're a very talented
couple.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I can't believe
she took that.
Horrible deal.
When they wake up,
they'll realize they messed up.
No, no.
She made a very smart deal,
given the risk
that this company has.
Both: No, Lori did
a great deal.
I think it's terrific.
I don't think
they got it.
Oh, you guys.
Do you believe
we did this?
Amber: In the end, it was
a really tough decision.
Every percent of equity
is coming from our family.
When Lori showed that she was
willing to compromise with us,
that she came to the 9%,
we knew that she was
the right partner
for our business.
Narrator: In season three,
the four Mastronardo brothers
made a deal with Barbara
for their line of skin-care
products, Nardo's Natural.
We welcome you
to the family.
Wow, great!
Come on down here!
All right, thank you.
You won't regret it.
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
Danny:
We've had an incredible year,
and it's been a roller coaster,
but things have
also been bittersweet.
When we came
on "shark tank,"
we were four brothers
with a family business.
Show them the face.
Please?
[ Laughter ]
Danny: Unfortunately,
earlier in the year,
we lost our baby brother K.J.
In a tragic accident.
It's been a tough time for us,
but we've stood together
and stayed strong.
D.J.:
Our recent tragedy has only
strengthened our family bond.
Now we're motivated
more than ever
to make our business
a success
'cause that's what K.J.
would have wanted.
Corcoran: Hey, guys.
All: Hey, Barbara.
Since partnering with Barbara,
our business has exploded,
and to date, we have
over $500,000 in sales.
I can't believe
the sales figures.
$500,000?!
Did you make that up?
Barbara's
been a guiding light,
and she took a leap of faith
with us.
I'm so proud of you.
And now with the growth
of our company,
we're talking to big-box
retailers like Whole Foods,
Walgreen's, and CVS.
Thank you for calling
Nardo's Natural.
How may I help you?
Before "shark tank,"
it was my brothers and I
making products
in the kitchen.
Let's start off right
and hit this month's quota,
and let's get some noise.
Come on.
Danny: And now we've created
jobs and have 14 sales reps...
It's looking good.
...and we have a full
manufacturing facility
and fulfillment center,
and it's great to see our
products going down the line.
Thanks to "shark tank,"
we're on our way
to becoming
a million-dollar company.
Good job.
A large piece of our family
and business has been lost,
but it's made us bond
as brothers,
and we're doing our best
to remain positive
to continue pursuing
the American dream.
Narrator: Next up
is a doctor with a product
inspired by her goal
to relieve pain and suffering.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Dr. Edna Ma,
a board-certified
anesthesiologist
and the creator of Bareease.
I'm seeking $50,000
in exchange for 20% equity
of my growing company.
As an anesthesiologist,
my life is all about pain
prevention and pain management.
So it was only natural
for me
to create a product
that would ease people's pain.
Allow me to introduce
Bareease.
[ Laughs ]
I wonder what it is.
Dr. Ma: Bareease
is a patented numbing kit
used before waxing or laser
so grooming the bikini line
doesn't have to be painful.
How does Bareease work?
The user wears the kit
before her appointment,
allowing time
to numb the skin.
Then immediately before her
service, she removes the kit,
and her skin will be ready
for ouchless hair removal.
And that could mean waxing,
laser, or even electrolysis.
Our proprietary formula
has been granted a patent
for its unique ability
to not just numb,
but to soothe
and moisturize the skin.
Now it is my goal to convince
at least one of you sharks
to grant me the privilege
of working with you
so we can grow Bareease
and show more women
that their grooming regimen
doesn't have to hurt.
I'm gonna hand out
some samples now
so you can try it in the privacy
of your own home.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: And this is
over the counter, right?
Thank you, Edna.
Dr. ma: Uh, yes. 4% Lidocaine
is the maximum strength
you can sell over the counter
without a prescription
in the United States.
Doctor, at any one time,
how many women
are about to get
blasted?
[ Laughs ]
I'm glad you asked
that question.
We worked with the
world-renowned Kinsey Institute
at Indiana university...
Indiana university.
...to quantify this market
and this potential
opportunity.
And according to
their research,
between 40%
and upwards of 80% of women
are grooming the bikini line,
and that includes all methods.
That seems remarkable
to me.
Yes.
Grooming the bikini line
is now considered
the new "cultural norm."
Overall --
and let me just say,
men are thankful.
[ Laughs ]
Men are doing this, too.
What?
Yes, manscaping.
Haven't you heard of it?
Yeah, that's true.
What happens to the package
if a man tries this?
Permanent numbing.
[ Laughs ]
This is
the men's version.
O'Leary: Doctor, are you --
are you serious?
This is dead serious.
We created a men's version, too.
It's called "numb"...
Fill in the blank.
Okay.
Numb cashews.
How do you apply that?
[ Laughs ]
How did you come up
with the idea?
A few years ago,
I got my first Brazilian wax,
and it was so painful.
As a physician that specializes
in pain prevention,
I knew that there
was a simple solution
to this painful problem.
So, you put the cream
on this?
You put the cream
on the targeted area,
then slip into the panty.
And the panty
helps isolate the cream
oh, I see.
And prevents
the transfer of the cream
onto your clothes.
There are numbing creams
on the market,
primarily for, like, canker
sores and for hemorrhoids,
but mine is specifically
targeting the bikini area.
So, it's more of
a branding issue
than it is anything else,
right?
Yes.
And then my product can be sold
over the counter.
Right.
Edna, how long have you
been selling it?
We've been selling
for about three years.
Together:
What are your sales?
Last year we sold
$45,000 worth of products,
and that's enough for us
to demonstrate proof of concept
in this new category
before --
and how about this year?
This year we're projected
to have $62,000
worth of sales.
$45,000 isn't a lot.
What do you think
has held you back?
For me, I think
it's distribution.
The majority of our sales
are online.
Edna, what do you
sell it for?
It sells for $18 retail
for the kit.
Wholesale?
Corcoran:
But it's a single-use...
And what --
what does it cost you
to make it?
...right?
It costs me $2.82.
How do you j--
divvy up your time
between your work as a doctor
and your business?
[ Sighs ]
That's a hard question.
I do practice medicine still.
I practice
in the academic setting,
teaching residents
and medical students,
and I have a job
in the private practice,
and then I have my family
and my little boy.
That's a lot.
I think the concern I've got is
I look at three years of effort,
and, you know, $40,000,
$50,000 in sales
in a market,
by your own definition,
that should be in the millions,
we're just not there.
And I think one
of the reasons
is that you just don't have
a full-time focus on this.
It's not
a company yet.
And it hasn't been
enough for you to say,
"okay, I have so much confidence
in this product,
I'm willing to leave everything
behind and focus on this."
You're absolutely right.
I wouldn't disagree with you.
This is a product
in just a baby infant company.
But I don't want to
just buy a product
and then have it be called
"Dr. Mark's Bareease,"
right?
No?
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate your time
in listening to me.
Edna, I think you
could certainly make
a business of this,
but to use your own analogy,
like a baby company,
and just like a baby,
it needs 150% of your attention.
And by you standing here
looking for a partner,
what I'm really hearing
between the lines
is you're looking for someone
to drive this business home.
And that's really
the job of the entrepreneur.
I would never ask one of you
to take over this product
because it requires such
a tremendous amount of time.
I know that.
But time you don't
have to really give.
Right. And so,
what I am looking for
is somebody
who has the experience
of taking a product like mine
and licensing it. Yeah.
And just getting
a license.
That's really what
you're after.
Exactly.
Yeah.
A licensing opportunity.
I'm not the girl for you.
I'm out.
Thank you for your time
and feedback.
O'Leary: I'm not sure
about the market size.
I think there's
a lot of competition
for how you desensitize
the area,
but I think what I've seen
from the sales
is that it really hasn't grown
as fast I would have liked.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mr. wonderful,
for your time and feedback.
Thank you.
I can tell you about --
my journey
is very similar to yours.
My parents,
they escaped communist China
to come
to the United States
for a better opportunity
for their kids.
And they worked in restaurants
all their life.
And they came over
not speaking any English.
And we worked in the restaurants
growing up.
And I know the definition
of a strong work ethic.
I'm not afraid of that.
I'm the first person in
my family to graduate college.
I think through me
and my sisters,
who also have doctorates,
we're living
their American dream.
You know, to me...
Mm-hmm.
I'm very impressed
by you
and your journey.
Thank you.
You have a long way
to go.
And also, there are
other things out there.
But I commend you
for what you've done.
Thank you.
And if I ever needed an
anesthesiologist, I'd want you.
Thank you.
I would -- I-I --
but I am going to be out.
Thank you, Lori,
for your time and feedback.
Herjavec: Edna, I --
yes, sir.
I think
it's an admirable start,
and thank you
for sharing your story with us.
You know, my dad
escaped from a jail,
brought us here on a boat,
just like your parents.
You can never underestimate
the work ethic
of somebody that comes
to this country
and appreciates what they have
every day.
Absolutely.
When I started my business,
here was the challenge --
I had a good job.
I didn't want to take the risk
of starting a company.
So, I kind of wanted
to start a company,
but I didn't want to
leave comfort.
I got fired, and I needed to
start a company
to make the next
mortgage payment.
So, I think it's hard
to leave comfort
until you have
some real pain.
Are you really gonna
leave the comforts
of doing what you're doing
and all that success
in order
to run this company?
My day job pays the bills.
It's a hobby.
It's not a business.
I wish you all the best,
but today, I-I'm out.
Thank you for your feedback
and time.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations
on a great start, Edna.
It's a great start.
Greiner:
Good luck, Edna.
Thank you.
I-I think my only point to her
was, at the end of the day,
entrepreneurism
has a risk,
and sometimes that risk
isn't worth taking.
Narrator:
Next into the tank is a business
with an innovative way
to get a tough job done.
[ Goat bleats]
Corcoran: Oh!
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Ohh!
Oh, my God.
[ Goat bleats ]
Oh, they're so cute.
Oh, look at them.
They're hungry.
Oh.
Hi, my name
is Matt Richmond.
And I'm Mike Canaday,
the goat guy.
Our company
is Rent a Goat,
and we're seeking $150,000
for 25% of our company.
[ Laughs ]
Sharks...
Rent a Goat is the answer
to a landscape disaster like
this -- an overgrown mess.
Now, usually
conventional landscapers
use pesticides, machinery,
or manual labor
to clean this mess up,
but you
probably don't know
there is an amazing
green alternative
to gas-guzzling machines
and cancerous chemicals.
That's right.
Rent a Goat helps businesses
and landowners
landscape their properties
in a safe and eco-friendly way
at a competitive price by
clearing their land with goats.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm not kidding.
See, that's a little
goat-industry joke.
You get it, Mark.
You see, goats
are simply a better way
to get
a tough job done,
plus these nimble little guys
can go where men
and machinery can't.
They don't pollute
and they naturally
fertilize as they work.
[ Laughter ]
I bet they do.
Sharks, the demand for this
green business is amazing.
We need your help to
get the goats out there
where they're needed.
Matt, you got to
tell us your story.
I mean, you wake up and say,
"I want goats." I mean, why?
I graduated college
in 2009.
And you thought "goat."
I thought goats, so, I went
to the Republic of Moldova.
Have you guys
heard of that?
Yes.
It's in eastern Europe.
And I saw they had
these little goats
on a little stake
with a rope,
and they would clear
these circles of land,
they move them to a different
spot, and before you know it,
you had these crop circles
in this big open field.
So, it wasn't
the new technology,
the expensive weed eaters
that cleared this land for them.
It was goats.
So, I started a website
called Rent a Goat
that connected goat wranglers
with customers.
I teamed up with Mike,
who's been on the website
for over three years.
Mike grosses
over $600,000 a year.
He knows
what he's doing.
Renting goats?
Renting goats.
Before he hooked up to you.
Yeah.
I'd like to understand how
this works a little bit better.
450 goats eat an acre a day.
An acre a day.
How much
does it cost somebody
to bring in 450 goats a day,
and who are those customers?
So, I analyzed
Mike's business,
and 70% of his customers
are homeowners associations
and municipalities.
We do
a homeowners association
right now
in Southern California,
and they had
about 130 acres.
It cost them $70,000.
And that's cheaper than having
a mechanical machine cut it?
Greiner:
And that is just to clear?
When they're doing
the weed-eating
with a person
with a weed eater like that,
it costs them
about $2,700 an acre.
How much
do you charge, Mike?
From $400 an acre
to $1,200 an acre.
Okay, so,
I get Mike's business.
He's got the goat business.
He's been doing it for a while.
How does Matt
come into the picture?
So, we're bringing 450 goats
down to San Diego.
Um, in over five years --
our fifth year
we're gonna grow $600,000,
and it's an average
R.O.I. of 45%.
What are you gonna do
in your fir--
okay,
now you're talking --
first year is $200,000.
You know what?
Projections are nice.
Projections
are guesses, right?
It's not a guess if we have
a model to base it on.
And we have all of the tools
necessary to make it happen,
including additional
marketing from me,
which we don't have
right now.
What are you gonna do
your first year?
First year -- $200,000.
That's conservative,
based on $1,000 per day
at 450 goats.
I get it.
I'm a little confused.
Does the Rent a Goat business
actually exist today,
or is this a new idea?
So, Rent a Goat itself,
the website existed since 2010.
We help connect those wranglers
to the customers.
How much revenue have
you generated since 2010?
None.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: That's bad.
Matt, that's generally bad.
It's not bad.
I got to hear why
it's not bad.
Well, I thought that
you said
you did $600,000.
We got to start
somewhere, right?
No, no, but that's
Mike's business.
We're getting confused 'cause
Mike has his own business.
Right.
It's got nothing
to do with Matt.
Aren't you two partners
coming in here?
We are.
Rent a Goat, llc.
in April.
Going forward.
We're starting
this location in San Diego.
What do I own
with my dough?
I write you a check,
what do I own?
You own 25%
of Rent a Goat, llc,
which is gonna be
our franchise,
our, um, corporate location
in San Diego.
Corcoran: But that doesn't
cover the goats.
Going to be, not today.
Look, I like
the business idea.
'Cause, right,
you're the first to the market,
so that gives you an edge,
but the problem is,
there's no barriers
to entry.
You just go out
and buy goats.
When there's a market
and there's money to be made,
it quickly becomes efficient
and the prices go down.
For that reason, I think
it's gonna be very difficult,
and I'm out.
We're always gonna have
competitors in our field.
I believe in this.
It's a great business
and it works.
It's totally dependent
on the Mikes of the world.
You're gonna locate them.
You're gonna convince them
to be decent managers,
to show up,
to bring their goats there,
to have the quality work
that you're gonna need
to continue the brand.
That's a problem.
I'm out.
You know, one -- I like goats.
They're cute.
Aren't they?
Two -- they just cleared out
all of that in minutes.
It works.
It's kind of crazy.
I love that it's green.
But problem for me
is it's just too soon.
It's just too early.
I'm out.
Lori, this is gonna be
a success,
and you know it is,
and you would love to add
a green business like this
to your portfolio.
The problem with this business,
I could just start up
Mr. wonderful's goat farm
myself.
Canady:
I'll bet you can't.
I'd hire a guy
and I'd say, "let's go goating."
Mike has over 30 years
of experience in his field.
I'd be buying your equipment
within three months.
[ Laughter ]
I believe this guy.
And I'd be giving you
less than half
what you paid for it.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be the goat shark.
The goat shark --
I like that.
Matt, I admire
the -- the idea,
but the business plan is
a little bit all over the map.
I'm out.
I'm not gonna ride your herd
into the sunset with you.
I don't think this business
is proprietary at all.
And I think if it makes as much
money as you predict it will...
It will.
...you're gonna have
a ton of competition.
And moving the goats around,
there's so much complexity
in the logistics
of this business.
That's why a lot
of people can't do it.
That's why it doesn't work.
Yeah, but I'm out.
Thanks, guys.
Greiner: Good luck.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Thank you so much.
Bye, goats.
Thank you.
See you, guys.
Corcoran: Bye-bye.
Greiner: Bye, goats.
That Mike is so cool,
isn't he?
Herjavec: I love Mike.
Yeah.
I think
he's a classic rancher.
I liked Mike.
I didn't know about Matt's plan.
He was a little bit, uh --
I don't know what Matt brings
to the table, frankly.
We didn't quite
get the business model.
You know, we went too far
afield with the website,
which in the beginning
we knew was a minefield.
Yeah.
And that's where
they went with it.
My name is Teresa fraijo.
This is my husband Robert.
We live in Laguna Niguel,
California,
with our two sons,
Vance and Maximillian.
And we are the creators
of Veggie Mama.
Broccoli --
why don't you try that?
No, I don't like that.
Come on!
Getting our children
to eat healthy has
always been a battle.
Eat it! It's yummmy.
Blech!
So, we had to get
a little bit more creative.
After experimenting
in the kitchen
with yummy smoothies
for our children...
Cheers!
...I had my "aha!" moment
and Veggie Mama was created.
What do you think
about this new box design?
I think
we should run with it.
Robert:
We pretty much put it
all on the line
for Veggie Mama.
I dropped out of law school.
We moved in with my parents.
Teresa: We've spent
every dime of our savings.
We've borrowed money
from family and friends.
And we even sold the diamond
out of my wedding ring,
so we have a lot
riding on this.
Ready?
Go get it!
My family
is so important to me.
They have been...
[ Voice breaking ]
They've been a huge, huge,
um, inspiration and help to us
to get this going,
and we couldn't have done it
without all of their help.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Teresa,
A.K.A. Veggie Mama.
And this is my husband,
Robert -- Veggie Papa.
We are the co-founders
of Veggie Mama
and are here today
seeking $75,000
in exchange
for 15% of our company.
Any parent knows it is not
always easy to get children --
or husbands --
to eat their vegetables,
but we have solved
that problem.
Veggie Mama has created
a delicious way
to sneak in those
essential nutrients.
When it comes
to snack time,
picky kids want
something fun and tasty --
spinach and beets -- probably
not gonna top their list.
So we took
the classic frozen pop
and snuck in real fruits
and real vegetables.
Veggie Mama garden pops
are frozen snacks
made with real fruits
and vegetables
and sweetened only
with organic agave nectar.
No artificial colors,
flavors, or preservatives.
This is not
frozen sugar water.
And we would love for you all
to try them now.
Our sons will sit
at the dinner table all night
before touching spinach,
but they love
our citrus cucumber flavor,
and it has a hearty helping
of spinach in it.
Herjavec: Teresa, what are
the flavors we have?
We have carrot Berry, citrus
cucumber, and sweet potato pie.
Wow.
It's really good.
Thank you.
This is gluten-free, this
is dairy-free, this is vegan.
I thought it was gonna taste
like crap, and it's pretty good.
Thank you.
Agave's very expensive, so what
is it costing you to make this?
Each package
costs around $1.10.
There's six pops
per package.
And what do you
wholesale it for?
We wholesale
to distributors for $2.25.
What are
your sales like?
Our total sales
are about $30,000.
Most of that $30,000 has come
within the last few weeks.
We started
with Whole Foods.
Now we just recently
got picked up
by Sprouts Farmers Markets,
so we're in all 160 Sprouts.
Tell me the journey
to get to the start.
Like, what's
your background?
My husband was
in law school last year,
and I've been mostly mama,
hence the Veggie Mama.
And just talking to moms,
they'd ask me,
"how do your kids eat
so healthy?"
And I would tell them,
"I make green smoothies."
And they kind of looked at me
like, "it's just too much work."
And I understand.
Moms are busy.
They need something
quick, easy.
So I said, "why can't I take
the smoothie idea,
combine fruit-and-vegetable
combinations
that create
this vibrant color,
and he was so much
more interested in
this than law school.
We said,
"hey, let's go for it."
Well, the best part
of all this --
one less lawyer,
so that's a good thing.
Yeah. That's what
my father would say.
Tell us
about your production.
What -- what --
how do you make it?
What's the capacity?
How much more could you make?
We definitely have room
for more production.
We can handle it.
We have our own facility
in Southern California.
How -- how much money did you
guys invest in this thing?
A total investment has
been about $140,000.
And the money is your own
personal money?
We have about $30,000
of our own,
and $110,000
from family and friends.
Who's running
the machinery?
We are.
I am full-time.
I am working
full-time, yes.
He has a separate
job full time.
How much are you making
in your job right now?
$67,000.
Okay.
For $67,000,
I could buy you
as a full-time employee
for this business, right?
Absolutely.
Guys, I'm gonna simplify it
for the other sharks here.
Um, I hate the frozen-food
business.
It's gonna be so expensive
to take this nationwide.
I don't know
that you're ready for it.
And more importantly,
I don't know that I'm
ready for the scramble.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
You have something very opposite
to every one of the partners
I'm in business with
in the food business.
You have $140,000 in cash
in your business
and you have $30,000
in sales.
Every one of my other four
partners initially,
at the same stage as you, had
roughly the reverse of that.
I'm afraid of the numbers.
And for that, I'm out.
You know,
I'll make you an offer.
I would give you
the $75,000.
And the way
I get paid back
is I'm gonna make 50 cents
off every unit sold
until I get
my capital back,
then it's gonna drop
to 25 cents.
I get no equity.
I've done this structure
other times with food.
I'd have you talk
to probably the people
that own wicked good cupcakes
'cause they're just like you.
And we've turned that
into a monster success.
Huge.
You want half
of everything they make?
It'll be half
for about 5h months.
There's no product
like this.
You've got to go
with this.
My only concern is $75,000
isn't enough money
for somebody to go out there
and do all that calling
and do the inventory
and get the cost of goods
and all the other stuff.
Here's my offer.
I'll give you $75,000
for 25%
and, probably within
the next 6 to 12 months, Robert,
for you to come back
into the business full time,
I'll give you
an additional $75,000,
so it doesn't have to
come out of the business.
So alogether
$150,000 for 25%.
Okay.
Thank you.
You're thinking
about that?
I'm thinking about that,
definitely.
We're open to listening
to any other offers.
I love the product.
I think it's great.
I'm going to make you
an offer.
I'm gonna give you
the $75,000,
and I would like 20%.
And if there needs
to be more money
and we're really rolling,
I'll provide it.
I can get us
into all of the best stores
because I have
all the connections.
And we're gonna build this
into the best
and number-one frozen veggie pop
in the world.
I'm gonna spice it up here
in the shark tank a little bit.
I'm gonna modify
my offer
because I actually think getting
Robert full time is crucial.
I write you a check
for $150,000,
you quit your job
tomorrow morning
or as soon
as you get the cash,
and then you start
selling this.
You start paying me
50 cents a unit
until I get
my $150,000 back.
After I get back my $150,000,
I get 25 cents a unit.
I'm your bank.
I don't need your equity.
Okay.
Well, you know, whenever Kevin
likes to spice things up,
it makes us want to
spice things up even more.
Okay.
Robert.
Herjavec: I want to come in
with Lori.
I'd love to be in on this
'cause I think
she believes in you guys
just like I believe in you guys.
I'll go down to the 20%.
So, $75,000 for 20%.
At the time that Robert's
ready to come back in,
we'll give you another
$75,000 for that salary.
But because you're getting
two of us,
we want a 20-cent royalty
along the way.
Ooh.
Now you have to give up
royalties and equity.
There's a lesson there.
When you offer
something for sale
and you put the deal
on the table and they say yes,
you don't look over
their shoulder.
Robert offered you
more than you asked for,
and you didn't respond.
Let me put this
in a different way.
When you walk
into the shark tank,
you look for the sucker,
and if you don't see one,
it's you.
Narrator:
Two sharks are out.
Teresa and Robert have
two offers on the table.
Kevin has offered $150,000
for a 50-cent royalty,
which goes down to 25 cents
after he recoups his investment.
Lori and Robert
have also offered $150,000,
but for a 20% stake,
plus a 20-cent royalty.
So, you're
one handshake away.
So, let me stop you and make you
think about something.
You have two offers
on the table,
but they both have royalties
you don't like.
You are in a very good
negotiating position.
Why don't you guys
go talk about it
and regroup a little bit?
We'll be right back.
Thank you all.
One moment.
Thank you.
Barbara, when did you become
the teacher of the tank?
Why do you have to
have the royalty?
Let's just drop it.
You know, Barbara,
I might have done that.
It's unfair.
A catfight.
Should we try to get
our equity down?
Or, I don't --
I think we should do away
with the royalty.
Me too.
When did you become
so crusty?
It's just annoying
because we're taking advantage
of these very good people.
You're being mean to Lori.
You're piping up
at all the wrong times.
What are you talking about?
Drop the royalty and hit
a home run with these people.
We're back.
Robert: We really
appreciate the offers,
and we appreciate
your experience
and the connections
that you have.
I think where we are stuck
is the 20-cent royalty.
What's your counter?
We'll keep
the $75,000 now,
$75,000 in the future
when we need Robert,
and keep you at 20%.
It's a good counter, but I want
to stay with the royalty.
You're getting the two of us.
It's a fair amount of equity.
A lower --
do you know that the 20-cent
royalty going forward...
A lower royalty
than Kevin's.
...is exactly 10%
of everything you sell.
You realize that?
That's like giving them
an extra 10% free stock.
Is that what you're after?
Are you coming back in, or are
you just gonna give more --
I may be coming back in 'cause
I'm getting so annoyed here.
No kidding, right?
You're getting
a lot of free advice here
from people who aren't
making you an offer.
And you know the value
of that free advice
is exactly what you're getting
for it -- nothing.
They're not making an offer.
Why don't we go
knock them out?
Let's go together
and drop the royalty.
Yeah, but I don't want to
do the work.
Well, I'll do the work.
You know I will.
You want to do the work?
Yeah, let's go in
and knock them out.
Guys, you know what?
We're tired of it.
75k for 20%,
done deal, no royalty.
Done.
Let's do it.
We would love to do
a deal with you.
Thank God.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys.
Cuban: [ Laughs ]
I would pay 75k
just to not listen
to that anymore.
Yeah, exactly.
It was enough already.
Good luck.
Robert: We envisioned ourselves
coming in here today,
leaving with a deal
with Mark Cuban and Barbara,
and at the end of the day,
that's exactly what we did.
Good job. Love you.
Love you.